[Musique]
avec vous ou line rifaï bonjour line
beauchamp pauline des diplomates
européens poursuivent donc ce jeudi
leurs discussions pour tenter de trouver
un compromis sur un cinquième train de
sanctions contre la russie est au
premier rang de ces sanctions
l'instauration d'un embargo sur le
charbon russe parce qu'on l'a dit encore
ces dernières heures sur le pétrole et
sur le gaz on est encore loin d'un
accord à quel point l'union européenne
d'abord l'hymne est-elle dépendant du
charbon en général et du charbon russe
en particulier l'or au cours de ces
dernières années de ces trois dernières
décennies pauline l'union européenne a
cherché à réduire sa consommation de
charbon sauf qu'en même temps est là
elle n'a pas baissé donc elle a cherché
à baisser sa consommation de charbon on
le voit ici de 1200 millions de tonnes
en 1990 à 427 millions de tonnes en 2020
donc baisse de la consommation pour
réduire l'empreinte carbone elle a en
même temps fermer des 1000 sauf que elle
a fermé ses mines à un rythme beaucoup
plus rapide qu'elle abaisser sa
consommation de charbon elle s'est
retrouvée donc très dépendante des
importations très rapidement et une
grande partie de ses importations et
bien elles proviennent de russie on va
voir cette dépendance aujourd'hui 45 %
des importations de charbon l'union
européenne viennent de russie et de
payer en particulier sont très
dépendants du charbon russe l'allemagne
et la pologne qui l'utilisent en
particulier pour produire leur
électricité le risque de voir un impact
sur les prix d'électricité au niveau de
toute l'europe écoutez l'analyse de cet
économiste ainsi pour cent de
l'électricité en europe provient du
charbon en france c'est beaucoup moins
c'est presque dix fois moins c'est un
peu moins de 2% par contre comme les
marchés européens sont très
interconnecté toute molécule de charbon
qui va manquer à un endroit et qui va
générer une perte d'électrons à ce même
endroit va avoir un impact sur la plaque
européenne mais les européens pauline
pourront tout de même se tourner vers
d'autres fournisseurs de charme au c'est
par exemple le cas des états unis on va
le voir dix sept et demi pour cent des
importations de charbon l'union
européenne viennent des etats-unis 16%
d'australie également d'autres
fournisseurs comme l'afrique du sud ou
l'indonésie
on ne va se passer du charbon russe
c'est pas très facile ça peut être
compliqué mais c'est possible parce que
les autres fournisseurs peuvent
augmenter leur production et donc se
substituer progressivement au charbon
oui c'est possible mais ça prend du
temps ça peut prendre du temps en effet
parce que les contrats sont déjà signés
et pour plusieurs mois les contrats sont
signés en avance donc pour les prochains
mois c'est d'ailleurs le principal sujet
d'achoppement des négociations en cours
alors il ya plusieurs possibilités
est ce que si on met en place un embargo
sur le charbon russe cela ça va
s'appliquer sur les nouveaux contrats
seulement ou est-ce qu'on l'appliqué sur
les contrats déjà en cours si on
applique sur les contrats déjà en cours
comment va-t-on faire pour se fournir
plus ou moins rapidement en charbon
auprès d'autres fournisseurs il ya une
piste qui est en discussion actuellement
au sein de l'union européenne une piste
parmi d'autres c'est l'extinction des
contrats au bout de 90 jours et puis
l'union européenne peut aussi s'inspirer
de ce qui a été fait outre manche au
royaume uni le royaume uni peut ainsi
décider l'arrêt des importations de
charbon russe d'ici la fin de l'année
alors là on parle de charbon les
européens on le sait l'union européenne
est très dépendante du pétrole et du gaz
russe également mais là s'en passer
c'est apparaît plus compliqué oui c'est
plus compliqué dit c'est difficile mais
c'est inéluctable comme l'a dit le
président du conseil européen charles
michel alors selon lui et vous l'avez
dit dans les titres ni européenne devra
prendre tôt ou tard je cite des
sanctions sur le pétrole et le gaz russe
alors est-ce que c'est faisable et avec
quelles implications on va voir ça
d'abord avec le pétrole la russie
fournit à plus de 25 % du brut du
pétrole de l'union européenne et
certains pays achètent même 75 % de leur
consommation dans noir c'est le cas de
pays comme la slovaquie la hongrie la
bulgarie ou encore la finlande l'union
européenne peuvent certes se tourner
vers d'autres fournisseurs de pétrole
notamment les pays du golfe mais pour le
moment il ne semble pas prêt pauline a
augmenté leur production de pétrole a
rapidement en tout cas pas de décision
en ce sens au sein de l'opep l'europe
est encore plus dépendante du gaz russe
elle est d'abord liée à la russie par un
réseau de gazoducs et 45 % de ses
importations de gaz viennent de russie
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que la
question d'un embargo sur le gaz divise
les européens pour l'allemagne et par
exemple le gaz russe représente 5 5 % de
l'ensemble des importations donc de gaz
l embargo sur l'énergie russe les
hydrocarbures russes en général pourrait
avoir un impact très important sur
l'économie allemande entre 0 3% et 3 %
de croissance en moins pour l'allemagne
en cas de telles sanctions
merci beaucoup line c'était